اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا في نافذه التحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
فيها نستضيف كالعاده المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز الدويري وكذلك ستكون معنا
اليوم سلام خضر على الخارطه التفاعليه
ونبدا معك سلام في استعراض الاحداث
الجاريه على الخارطه شكرا مياده سنبدا من
جنوب القطاع قبل هذه الفقره ببضع دقائق
تواصلنا مع الزميل اسماعيل ابو عمر في
جنوب قطاع غزه تحديدا في منطقه خانيونس
سالناه عن حجم المعارك بعد كلام وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوم امس بان هناك الويه
قد سحبت وان العمليه العسكريه بدات تخف
لان بحسب ما قال طبعا يوف جالنت ال هناك
خسائر كبيره منيت بها كتائب القسام قال
اسماعيل لنا ان العمليات العسكريه في
الجنوب لم تخف حدتها وما زالت قائمه كما
كانت منذ عده ايام تتركز هذه المعارك
تحديدا في المناطق الغربيه والشماليه
الغربيه وايضا الجنوبيه الغربيه تترافق
العمليات العسكريه مع تحليق مكثف واستهداف
من الطائرات المقاتله الاسرائيليه على عده
مواقع تتزامن ايضا مع تفجيرات تنفذها قوات
الاحتلال في بعض المناطق وما زالت تحاول
الدفع باليات اعمق الى داخل مدينه خانيونس
لكن تواجه بمقاومه ضاريه من قبل كتائب
القسام وايضا سرايا القدس اليوم ايضا في
جنوب القطاع قرب مدينه خانيونس في المنطقه
الغربيه هناك استهدافات بقذائف محموله على
الكتف لعده اليات اسرائيليه دبابتين
ميركافا على الاقل وايضا اليه اسرائيليه
اضافيه بحسب ما اعلنت كتائب القسام وايضا
بحسب ما اعلنت سرايا القدس اللافت اليوم
في المنطقه الوسطى هو اعلان قوات الاحتلال
عن ان وحده عسكريه تابعه لها عثرت كما
تقول قوات الاحتلال على مخازن اسلحه في
مخيمي البريج والمغازي
وذخائر قالت انها ايضا عمدت الى تفجيرها
بالانتقال سريعا الى المنطقه الشماليه امس
كنا نتحدث عن عمليه اعاده تموضع واسعه من
قبل قوات الاحتلال في اكثر من منطقه لا
سما من المناطق الغربيه وقلنا امس بانها
انسحبت هذه الاليات الى ما بعد منطقه
عطاطره بحسب افادات شهود عيان وايضا بحسب
ما اكد الزميل انس الشريف الموجود في
المنطقه الشماليه يبدو ان هذه الانسحابات
ونقول انسحابات بين قوسين نفضل ان نسميها
اعاده تموضع لا تزال تكمل اليوم المنطقه
من العطاطه وصولا الى المناطق الشماليه في
مدينه غزه لم يعد هناك من اثر ليات قوات
الاحتلال ولكن بحسب ما هو ومتاح لنا من
معلومات يبدو ان هذه ال الانسحابات تهدف
الى تمركز الاليات في المنطقه اقصى شرق
قطاع غزه تزامنت هذه الانسحابات او اعاده
التموضع مع ما سربه الاعلام الامريكي
وكاله الاسوشيتد بريس تحدثت عن ان ما
تسميها اسرائيل بالمنطقه العازله التي
ستكون بعمق كيلومتر واحد داخل قطاع غزه من
الشمال من اقصى نقطه في الشمال الى اقصى
نقطه في الجنوب ستتوج بنحو كيلومتر واحد
باتت شبه جاهزه للانشاء ولكن هل ستنجح
قوات الاحتلال بانشاء هذه المنطقه العازله
وايضا الاهداف من ورائها وقراءه اعمق معك
مياده واللواء الدويري شكرا جزيلا لك سلام
اذا من هذه الخارطه لواء فائز ونبدا من
الشمال تحديدا حيث ان الشمال بالفعل في كل
مره يعود الى قلب الاحداث رغم انسحابات
كبيره حدثت في الشمال اشتباكات لا تزال
جاريه وهناك عمليات تجري في الشمال بدايه
كيف تقيم الوضع في الشمال يعني الوضع في
الشمال تقريبا انسحبت معظم القوات والقوات
التي تدخل في منطقه تل الهواء والشيخ
عجلين هي ليست من القوات التابعه للفرقه
162 التي انسحبت لانه تلك القوات انسحبت
الى ما خلف السياج او بعمر محدود داخل
قطاع غزه القوات التي تنفذ هذه العمليات
هي تابعه للاليه المتواجده في وادي غزه
وتدخل من منطقه الشيخ عجلين باتجاه تل
الهواء وبالتالي الفيديوهات التي صدرت امس
واول امس بينت نوع او درجه حده القتال في
تلك المنطقه
لانه كما تابعنا انه القسام اعاد تاهيل
قواته لواء غزه ولواء الش شمال الان
المعضله الرئيسيه واثارتها سلام عندما
تحدثت عن المنطقه العازله المنطقه العازله
منذ فتره بدا بدا التحضير لانشائها لا
اقول انشائها وهي تاخذ بالحد العام
بالمتوسط العام بعمق 1 كيل متر على طول
الواجهه الشماليه والواجهه الشرقيه وهناك
الحديث عن مع معبر فيلادلفيا اذا اردنا ان
نحسب هذه المساحه فقط دون ذكر هو في وادي
غزه نحن نتحدث عن حوالي 55 56 م مربع من
اصل 263 م مربع لكن التاريخ على هو هو هو
المرجعيه في 2005 كان هناك منطقه عازله
لانه قبلها كانت اسرائيل تحتل القطاع
واجبرت على الخروج وحاولت فرض منطقه عازله
بالنيران وحاولت ان تمنع مستوى المزارعين
لكن كان الرد هو رد شعبي اكثر م ما هو هو
رد من قب المقاومه عندما الجمع يذكر
مسيرات العوده وبالتالي اجهضوا هذه هذا
الوضع الان الوضع مرتبك لا اقول لانه كانت
في ايام مسيرات العوده كانت غزه هي غزه
ليست غزه المدمره ليست غزه اللي فيها اكثر
من 1.3 مليون نازح اذا هذ هذه الاجراءات
هي اجراءات استباقيه لما قد تؤول اليه
الامور خاصه في ظل الان الحديث عن وقف
اطلاق نار طيب نبقى قليلا في الشمال
وتحديدا جزئيه الانسحابات كيف تقرا ما
يجري هل هو اعاده تموضع هل هو انسحاب كامل
م لذيذ لا هو ليس انسحاب بمعنى انسحاب هو
اعاده اعاده انتشار دعينا نسمي اعاده
تموضع او اعاده انتشار لانه معظم هذه
الوحدات هذه كان فيها ثلاث فرق ابقي على
فرقه على فرقه سحب لواء ابقي على لوائين
الان تم سحبها ام الى الشمال من السياج
والى الشرق من السياج معظمها لكنها تدخل
باستمرار كلما لاحظت اي حركه مشبوهه تدخل
هذه القوات و يكون تشكيلها اللي القوات
مدرعه
واليه الميكانيكيه او الاليه مدعومه
بال الجارفه
الدينا التي هي تسهل عمل الوحدات المقاتله
طيب نتجه قليلا نحو الوسط وما اعلنه
المتحدث باسم الجيش عن تفكيك مجمع لصناعه
اسلحه ومنع نقل الاسلحه والافراد نحو من
الشمال نحو الوسط والجنوب الوضع القتالي
في البدايه ثابت منذ ايام و منذ اسابيع
وكان كلا
الجانبين خفض من وتيره التصعيد كل له
اسبابه الجانب الاسرائيلي لم يفلح في في
اقتحام المخيمات
اشهر وهو يحاول لكنه فشر بالمقابل
المقاتلين كذلك سيكون فتره اعاده التنظيم
الان حصلوا على مستودع للاسلحه امر وارد
جدا وبالتالي سيتم تدميره سواء كان
بالانفاق او ف فوق سطح الارض يبقى امر
اعتيادي ممكن حدوثه ا طيب ايضا ان ذهبنا
الى الجنوب تحديدا خان يونس هنا تحديدا
كان الحديث عن تفكيك كتيبه خان يونس وفق
ما قال جلنت وانه ستكون الخطوه القادمه
رفح رفع كيف تقيم هذا التصريح هو هو ذكر
نفس العباره عن اي شمال قطاع غزه قال تم
تفكيك ك الكتائب وتبين لاحقا بعد 48 ساعه
ان الكتائب لم لم تفكك وبالتالي هو يتحدث
عن كتيبه خان يونس انا اتحدث عن لواء خان
يونس لانه هو لواء حقيقه وليس كتيبه
ومدعوم بقوات النخبه من الفصائل الثانيه
الان اشار سلام ان المعارك هي على نفس
الوتيره كما هو في الايام السابقه القتال
لا يزال يدور دون تحقيق ايه انجازات تذكر
اسمح لي ان اقاطعك فقط ونعود الى الشمال
الان في خبر عاجل مراسل الجزيره يقول ان
هناك مواجهات عنيفه في مناطق غرب مدينه
غزه وفي محيط الصناعه وشارع الشهداء جنوب
حي الرمال الشمال في بؤره الاحداث انا قلت
قبل قليل انه منطقه تل الهواء والرمال هي
تاتيها القوات ليس من القوات التي انسحبت
انما من القوات الموجوده في وادي غزه انا
ذكرت قبل قليل يحتال هي هذه القوات تدخل
باستمرار يعني في اي لحظه تتوفر معلومه عن
وجود مقاتلين ان او اخبار ولو كانت زائفه
عن وجود رهائن الى غير ذلك تدخل هذه
القوات تشتبك مع المقاومين ومن ثم تتراجع
يعني لا يوجد تثبت بمعنى او تثبت مؤقت غير
موجود اصلا هي هذه الخارطه عندما كنا
نعرضها باللون الاصفر كنا نقول هذه مناطق
حركه القوات ومناطق الاشتباك فبالتالي هذا
متوقع في منطقه تل الهواء والرمال والشيخ
عجلين وهذا الحدث بالامس كان فيديوهات من
تل الهواء وكانت واضحه جدا شكرا جزيلا لك
لواء فايز الدويري نكتفي بهذا القدر في
هذه الاطلاله اذا ونتابع دائما الاحداث
العسكريه معك شكرا جزيلا لك وشكر موصول لك
سلام خضر شكرا